[Applause]
oh is that your molar
[Music]
my name is uh jorge perez i'm 21 years
old i'm single as all hell do you like
asmr i i i love asmr i've been an asmr
fan since
i discovered what it was back in like
2011. like i literally cannot fall
asleep without you somewhere and what
are you expecting from today uh get some
some bomb tingles i guess
if i were to meet somebody today you
know that'd be even better
are they like behind me yes they're
behind you hello
oh that's all that's really bright
hi
um this is me candice
can i talk rugby what are we
my ideal first date would probably be
something like on the beach with like a
sunset some good food maybe a little
wine we're feeling like snazzy
hi my name's
my ideal first date would be something
really fun like six flags or something
like smoke
hi
my name is marina or marina okay nice to
meet you or talk to you nice to talk to
you too marina i would say my ideal
first date would definitely be like an
escape room because i really love
puzzles or maybe like some kind of vr
experience and then maybe like some
drinks after just to kind of end the
night
hi
i'm celine
[Laughter]
a really fun first date would be like
going to like roller disco and then
maybe after
get some frozen yogurt
iora
it's like the city paris but with a k um
maybe for our first date you could bring
like food of your choice and then i
could bring like a drink and we can have
like a nice little picnic i don't know
get some like ice cream or boba after
hi
my name is kristen how are you
i feel like super relaxed now i feel
very comfortable with my voice yeah your
voice definitely does help my ideal
first date i really love food
to eat person but i think that going
grocery shopping is a really great like
introduction just like a good
conversation happens in the grocery
stores thank you for your time
thank you
[Music]
oh my goodness um
i'm gonna go ahead and say bye to
candice
and two and four
[Music]
one social
just walk up here
i don't even wanna look i'm like i'm
ashamed
oh my god i'm so sorry when i mentioned
smoking it was a little bit yeah but you
know it's okay it's okay you're killing
me
i'm so sorry
yeah he was cute i just wish he was more
assertive
oh my god
i'm so sorry it's fine
i mean i'm a pisces so i get it so it's
all good
this is marina
so
i'm a really big fan of self-care and
relaxation what we're going to begin
with first is we're going to close our
eyes
and we're going to take a deep breath in
ready do it with me deep breath in
deep breath out
deep breath in
now you're gonna imagine yourself in a
tropical paradise i'm gonna open this up
and it is a moisturizing face mask
[Applause]
okay and just imagine the cool mask on
your face
as you're rubbing in the serum from the
mask
i'm gonna go ahead and brush your hair
okay
you're relaxing
and all you can think about is being on
that tropical beach
listening to the waves crash as i brush
your hair
you can feel the salty sea on your skin
and now you can take off your mask
and open your eyes
thank you that
was amazing
hi
it's me garrus
i brought some of my favorite items
and maybe you can guess what they are
the first item is one of my favorite
hobbies
i like to do it at the beach
that
i have
zero clue what that is it sounds like
sand like scrapings that's like the
weirdest description it's a roller skate
oh it's a roller skate it's it's not
like something like like rolling but
that's not what i was gonna guess at all
i'll do my second sound
i feel like that was pretty obvious
that's not like
like an airsoft gun going off did you
bring like an industrial drill or
something like like a nail gun
thank you for letting me share them with
you thank you for having the patience
with me i appreciate it
it starts with a k right it starts with
a k and ends
[Applause]
so i really like peanuts peanut butter
all them nuts not in a sexual way
so we have a
rice crisp with peanut chunks original
flavor
are you hungry
i've been hungry this whole shoot and
now it's just like hitting me even more
up next we have more peanuts
have you ever had japanese peanuts
i don't think i've ever had japanese
peanuts
[Applause]
oh is that your molar
so this is the sound of my film camera
so i'm gonna take a phone photo right
now and maybe in a few weeks after these
get developed you can see
i have a sentient little guy
i hope you liked commented and
subscribed and turn on the post
notifications
thank you
do i get to keep your house keys too
uh
first off i just want to say you ladies
did amazing that was like top-notch asmr
i would subscribe to each and every one
of your channels
oh boy
this is tough my hands are so sweaty if
you guys can feel my hands you guys have
like a towel or like a wet wipe i'm
gonna choose the girl who i feel like
immediately i was kind of like yeah i
like her voice and uh i think she made
me laugh the most too
i'm gonna go with i'm gonna choose
contestant number six kristen
as my final
choice from the moment kristen went up i
i kind of just like
kept her in the back of my mind like
keeping like an ear out for not an eye
out but nero
okay
bye
honestly if i was in jorge's position i
would have chosen her the type of asmr i
listened to was like slime and the um
the soap oh i love the soap videos
kristen and marina like they were
putting in work
and i was just making him guess like
what my favorite items are
[Music]
i don't want to look i'm like like
oh my gosh you're so lovely hi thank you
for the ac was this helpful it was
extremely helpful
nice to meet you nice to meet you i'm
jorge i'm kristen
these are the japanese people oh there's
japanese nuts half of my rice crisps
it looks very good
pleasantly surprised yeah i think she's
like really pretty
yeah from the back i was like
very nice back very muscular arms
[Applause]
oh my god this is
extremely nerve-wracking because um okay
i've i've always wanted to do this loki
i don't even know how loud i should be
whispering
i can see you're already laughing so
that's that's a good sign welcome back
to my channel guys
it's your boy
asmr
or hey here we have kristen in the hot
seat today and we're gonna do some asmr
for
i'm going to uh brush your face now
kristen
i don't know if you yourself get asmr or
tingles or anything like that
uh but hopefully after this
you might i don't know what's gonna
happen but
here you go